jurassic world dominion has given us a
lot we are flooded with an emotional
reunion and a painful reminder that the
series has come to an end but with all
that comes amazing stories that even
some of the original cast members of
jurassic park get to spill the beans
about we wonder what it would have been
like to have that much star power on set
number one this one's been talked about
for a long time and what a legendary
reunion it was jeff goldblum laura dern
and sam neil came together to make one
awesome end to the franchise we all are
really happy it happened but imagine how
the jurassic world cast felt working
alongside them mama duate was in a loop
over being in a scene with jeff that it
felt super bizarre to him
what's going on here it was the most
bizarre feeling i ever had and as
filming came to an end let's just say
the entire cast's dreams came true
getting to befriend them as for how the
original trio was feeling about their
return well their emotions almost got
the best of them there was something
very nostalgic about being back together
their first scene was driving a jeep
down a dirt road and as soon as director
colin trevaro yelled cut
the crew could not contain themselves
we'd like to say we'd keep our cool on
set for this moment but nope we wouldn't
have lasted a second seeing goldblum in
his jacket again number two the original
jurassic park franchise ushered in a
whole new spectacle with animatronics
steven spielberg had a vision and it was
going to be done perfectly for the film
as for the cast in jurassic world they
may have had a rough time with them well
let's clarify it wasn't so much the
animatronics but these cgi dinosaurs
causing confusion precision and eye
movements were key in selling the
effects
and combine that with blocking makes for
a pretty chaotic experience but how do
they really sell those realistic dinos
according to bryce dallas howard looks
like steven spielberg apparently filmed
his own dogs fighting and sent it to
colin as a reference a little strange
way to get the movements they want but
hey it looks like the doggos were okay
in the end we really just can't get over
dewanda wise's reaction to it though
three even a big action star like chris
pratt takes a hard fall from time to
time but this one just really solidified
our fear of horseback riding it looks to
us like this fall was supposed to happen
in the final film but doesn't mean it
didn't hurt though chris can still do it
and gets right back on his saddle number
four dewanda wise had a very specific
idea for her character's hairstyle
braids and let's just say when it came
time for her big hero moment a lot of
people took note of it it wouldn't be an
adventure blockbuster without someone
saving someone from drowning and dwise
got the great pleasure of saving chris
on this one you're willing to risk your
life for people you've never met this
moment was very emotional for her she
described getting the braids explaining
the experience of getting them was black
womanhood at its finest it was as it is
a deeply fulfilling spiritual ritual a
precious thing it just felt like having
family there with me in the process
number five chris pratt's got a lot of
great ideas but trying to persuade bryce
dallas howard to jump out of a plane not
the best one the last day it'd be good
for the movie
chrysalis really feeling the tom cruise
daredevil vibe on set for a scene in
which bryce's character was supposed to
dive out of a plane but did she give in
to chris's wishes she gave that request
a big heck no filmmakers were definitely
not on board either there's really not a
lot of actors other than tom that really
put themselves in danger for a film
number six who loves a classic dad joke
no well chris pratt literally embodies
one through his flexibility sessions on
set he's gotta stay limber to get away
from the dinos
i just ran 65 miles an hour but does he
have to be so extra about it can't tear
those hamstrings well since bryce sees
him as the older brother on set of
course he's gotta live up to those extra
vibes number seven wait no more heals
you all should know by now what we're
talking about you know all that media
chaos surrounding howard running away
from dinosaurs like a boss as much as we
loved seeing this she was just over it
after the first one was way harder than
you would ever think she was indeed
asked to wear them for dominion but she
made it very apparent she was not
dealing with the sore feet again
although she was a little tempted to
out-heal her co-star chris pratt who
unbeknownst to us can rock heels better
than a lot of us ever could number eight
talk about cramming we all know the
feeling of cramming for a last minute
assignment or just putting off cleaning
our rooms but dewanda wise really pushed
that whole idea super close
after she was casted for the role of
kayla watts she thought to herself i
should probably look into the whole
jurassic world thing she not only hadn't
read the books she didn't even see the
films and she probably needed to get a
whole feel of the overall story so she
did all of that she literally crammed
all five films and read every single
book to prepare for her new role we
completely understand we'd probably feel
more motivated too if we were working
alongside such a legendary cast number
nine step aside howard you've got some
cackling competition now if you've
watched any of the bloopers of the
jurassic world franchise you'd know
she's got quite the cackle on set but
now dewanda joins the group and the
cackled duo is formed we have a very
similar version
her laugh is so similar to bryce's that
wise's own husband mistakenly thought
howard's laugh was his own wife's oh my
wife not to mention both of the leading
ladies are notorious for corpsing during
their scenes so they're just two of a
kind number 10 we don't blame the wise
dewanda here stick shifting is just way
too hard she had such a rough time
driving the jeep on terrain that her
stunt double skills were put to work
wise actually blames the vehicle of
choice for her inability to drive it but
come on there's no shame in admitting
you can't drive a stick shift number 11.
we've all heard the idea of directors
picking certain cast members without
auditions but for every cast member in a
film pretty unheard of
colin trevorrow reportedly did not
require an audition for his cast he just
chose them out of confidence in their
earlier works that's a lot of faith to
be had in actors jeff goldblum of all
people even had to audition for
spielberg for jurassic park number 12.
so the end may not be coming after all
jeff had a lot to say regarding future
jurassic projects and one he would not
expand upon was the fact that it may not
be ending so soon there may be more
things to the book i don't know
let's hope this isn't another classic
gold bloom joke because it would mean so
much to so many fans to keep this
franchise going number 13 this film like
many was filmed during the pandemic and
unlike many other productions during the
time they just kept at it filmmakers had
absolutely no clue what was to come but
all they could do was improvise in the
moment it was it was scary and we were
making a movie about that at the same
time they decided it was best to have
the cast and crew live together during
the shoot taking breaks throughout their
week to bond and work on lines not such
a bad time to be cooped up with such an
amazing cast the real amazing part about
their experience was it actually
mirrored the story they were filming the
world hung in the balance and all there
was to get us through the peak was hope
number 14 road trips aren't usually
productive for us all we usually do is
hope the next exit has a bathroom but
when director colin and writer derek
connelly took a little road trip they
were nothing but productive they came up
with an entire outline of how they
wanted dominion to go and ended up
presenting it to the other lead writer
emily carmichael that's just amazing how
such a big blockbuster can start on a
road trip number 15 the time has come to
say goodbye well
hopefully not but for the main cast of
the jurassic world franchise it seems
like it may be for them bryce dallas
howard was very emotional leaving behind
such a huge cast and story we just
couldn't help but cry with her so this
might not be the end but it very well
looks like the end of an era we're so
glad the franchise was able to end on a
good note and that all the funny stories
can be told thanks to jeff goldblum
maybe we have some hope for more or he
could have just been messing with us
wouldn't rule that one out so what do
you think they should do end it on a
good note or keep going let us know in
the comments